MALE SPEAKER: Which brings our
event to its closing moments,
and gives me great pleasure
to invite the person who
brought it all
together onto stage.
Mr. Rupert Whitehead.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Rupert.
And some closing words.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: Well,
thank you everybody.
I mean, when we were first
putting this event together,
I was trying to think about
how we could squeeze the Google
world for developers--
or games developers--
into one single day.
And we've had a
really crammed day,
but I don't think we've actually
managed to cover everything.
So we haven't
touched Chromecast,
we haven't touched the web as
much as we could have done,
and there have just
been hints about some
of these other things
around the edges.
It's a big world, but it's
a really exciting place.
So in terms of what
I wanted people
to get out of
this, first of all,
it's understanding
a little bit more
about where Google
plays in this space.
So what is it that we're
doing the makes us relevant
and will help you in your
world as games developers?
So I hope we've got more
of an idea of that now.
The second thing is, as
we've dived into the details
of things like AdMob,
things like Google+,
things like Games Play services,
you can see how that is going
to add concrete value
to your studios as well.
And I hope also,
you've got the chance
to meet some really
interesting people
and chatted to
them in the break.
So if you've ticked all
of those three things,
I think we've done
pretty well today.
Now, it's actually kind of
an exciting time in Google,
because there's stuff that's
being announced all the time.
And literally, at
this minute, there's
breaking news coming
from San Francisco.
We've got a big Cloud
event that's running there.
And Urs, who heads up
our infrastructure, that
runs all of our
Google services, is
making a big
announcement about Cloud.
And he's making an
announcement on a number
of different points.
So I haven't been able to
share slides with you on this,
but I wanted to give you
some of the headlines,
so you can go away,
think about that.
And take that with you.
And the first big
change is around price.
So in Google, we're a little
bit concerned in the sense
that you've got Moore's Law.
And that's creating an
erosion of price on hardware,
but you're not necessarily
getting those price
reductions-- in the
erosion of price
on hardware-- that gets
translated to you as a Cloud
customer.
So the first big thing that
we're actually offering
is a 32% price drop in Compute
Engine, a 30% drop for App
Engine, a 68% drop
for Cloud Storage,
which is pretty massive,
and a huge 85% percent cut
for Big Query-- which
we believe is about 75%
cheaper than any
other alternative.
So we are expecting this to
have a significant impact
on the Cloud landscape as well.
So all of you will have
with you some App Credits
as well-- some Cloud
Credits-- that you
go in those little note pads.
So use those.
Explore the Cloud platform,
and get to know it better,
because it's incredibly
cost competitive right now.
The second big announcement
that Urs will be talking about,
or is talking about,
is about simplicity.
To understand the pricing models
of Cloud worlds is complex.
So figuring out things
like reserved instances,
and exactly how much you're
going to pay is a tricky art.
So what we're actually
implementing now
is something called automatic
discounts for steady state
workloads.
So that makes it a
lot simpler for you.
We check your usage
over a monthly period,
and then apply the price drops
right at the end of the month,
and so you actually make
some massive savings on that
as well.
So in effect, you can save up
to about 53% for Compute Engine,
instance is if you've
got 24 by 7 usage.
So again, big cost
savings there.
He's announcing about new
operating system support.
So we'll have Susie and Red Hat
support, Windows Server 2008
R2, and we're also
supporting Cloud DNS.
And so you can have DNS
as a service as well.
And finally, we're
also building more
on what Mandy was talking
about earlier, blurring
this distinction
between infrastructure
as a service and
platform as a service.
So making this much
more of a continuum.
So in the past,
you typically have
some sort of sense
of compromise.
If you wanted the auto-scaling
functionality of App Engine,
but maybe a language
wasn't supported on it,
you might have to go
towards Compute Engine,
but you wouldn't have
the auto-scale with it.
But now with this hybrid model,
with managed VMs, which is now
in production, you can go beyond
that traditional compromise.
You run whatever you want,
auto-scale it as well,
on App Engine with
this managed VM model.
And so summarizing all of that,
because that's quite a lot
to take on board there.
I guess you can take away
that we're pretty committed
to Cloud, and that's
pretty important to us.
Second, we're committed
to simplicity.
We want to make it easier to
understand the Cloud, easier
to be billed about
that, and easier
to be able to predict things.
And third, we are
rethinking the way
Cloud computing can be done
with this hybrid model.
So ultimately, all of
this should save you
time and money and effort.
So lots to talk about there,
and lots to take in there.
But the other thing
to mention, as well,
is we're going to be
running a Cloud roadshow.
So there are going to be
27 locations globally.
And there's one in
London, one in Manchester,
various events in the
Nordics, Italy, and so on.
So have a look at this
URL here, scan it later,
and explore that further.
Because the Cloud
roadshow is going
to be where you can learn
a lot more about what we're
doing in Cloud, and whether
that makes sense for you,
and how it makes sense for you.
So you can get a
next level of details
and get much more of an
unpacking of these Cloud
announcements than I've been
able to do justice to here.
So in our closing words
really, a few impressions.
I mean, listening
to Dan's talk, there
was a lot to take
on board there.
There was the social
graph, multiplayer
for iOS and Android,
increasing people's ratings,
the Unity support.
But ultimately,
when I was looking
at a lot of those pieces
that come together,
it's about engagement.
And so how do you create a
much more engaging experience
with your players to really
build loyalty, build your game
up, and build your following,
and ultimately revenue?
And Games Play
Services has clearly
got a pretty critical
role to do there.
On the analytics side,
again, engagement
is another running theme.
How do you make
sure you understand
exactly what your
customers are doing?
And actually, it
ties in quite neatly
to one of the things that
came up on the panel.
Because actually, work starts
after you launch a game now.
And that's really where
analytics fits in quite nicely,
as well.
Beginning to study
exactly where it
is that you can
retain your users,
retain them, grow them, and
create the optimal gaming
experience.
And so hopefully you've
got some good sense
of where we go from there.
And on the subject of
the panel, one thing
I kind of took away from
it-- even though it sounded
like kind of a pessimistic
title-- was this
is actually the best time
to be a game maker ever.
And I think that kind of
comes through consistently
from pretty much all of
the talks that we've heard.
We're in a really exciting time.
We're just getting
started, in a way.
Lots of the pieces are
coming together now
to really be quite
transformative
and that's going
to be good to see.
With YouTube we
learned a lot more
about growing your
audience and engagement.
And [INAUDIBLE] talk
on their experiences
of growing rapidly and scaling
very quickly, I think, show
about that sort of
sense of the opportunity
that there is out there for us
as an industry-- and for games
developers, in
particular-- to go massive.
And understanding that
going massive is great,
but being prepared for it and
having the right infrastructure
behind you is also a pretty
important piece as well.
So that was an
excellent talk there.
And [INAUDIBLE]
with AdMob talking
about all of these different
ways that you can monetize.
Lots of new announcements like
the in-app purchase ad formats,
having analytics
now more integrated
together, ad network management,
the app developer business kit.
All of this driving
towards an increased
revenue, which is valuable.
And then we moved on to Addy's
talk, with Growing with Google.
And for me, that was
about demonstration
we have a much more
joined up Google.
This is not just
about social network,
it's about the identity
layer across Google,
and where identity
is important to you,
understanding your users.
So it's about reach,
its about discovery,
it's about acquisition,
it's about personalization,
it's about retention,
and it's about the power
of recommendation to bring
new people to your game,
to make it stick here and
make it more effective.
And then of course, with Noah's
talk, on the future of gaming,
I mean, that's incredibly
thought-provoking.
And I think we all feel that
it's such an exciting space,
and there's so far that
we've still got to go.
It's a nice place to be.
So the last thing to say
is thank you all very much,
particularly our speakers,
and the events team, and Rich,
for doing a great
job MCing, and mostly
to you for making this
such a fantastic day.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]